the north las vegas police department is
under new leadership today we spoke
one-on-one with the appointed chief and
assistant chief to see exactly how they
plan to move the department forward the
duo also making headlines by becoming
the first black leaders
jacqueline gravatt
i am the chief of police for the north
las vegas police department feels nice
to say that
yes it's a new day for the north las
vegas police department jacqueline
gravatt started with the department in
2001 as a patrol officer and hasn't
stopped working to better her community
i believe that with
keeping the focus on what's important
you know quality of life for our
citizens being involved with the
community the mother of two has been
serving as acting chief since the
beginning of the year when former chief
pamela ojeda retired after more than 25
years although the crime rate is down 35
percent from a decade ago she says the
department will focus on recruiting and
community engagement we have a ground
breaking coming up for new area command
gravad is not facing this challenge
alone as captain michael harris moves up
as assistant chief and claims the work
to improving the department is already
underway we are
looking to
get to any and every neighborhood that
we can
to create not only the diverse police
department but a fully staffed police
department both seeking to diversify the
police department to reflect the
community they serve while also becoming
the first black duo in leadership we
want our kids to really see how involved
and passionate we are about
changing what the face of law
enforcement
is the police chief is also coaching one
of four city soccer leagues which her
two daughters are part of she says north
las vegas residents can expect more
police presence in the community to
strengthen the trust